and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Wilburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today we're gonna talk about
what minimalism looks like when it's
taken to its extremes and we're gonna do
that with today's guests um is in the
studio as you'll notice I'm actually
exactly being near you you'll you'll
notice I'm actually not in the studio
today and it's because I am
self-quarantine I have a few cold like
symptoms and I don't know whether or not
that is the corona virus but I want
everyone to be safe and so I am here at
home if you're watching this on youtube
you can see that I'm seated in my living
room where we're having this
conversation so you may not get the same
pristine sort of audio that you would
usually get but we're doing our best to
make it as high quality as possible now
you um thank you so much for being in
the studio with us you have an amazing
youtube channel we'll put a link to it
in the show notes it's called heal your
living and people often here at Ryan and
I talk about minimalism not being a
radical lifestyle it's often a practical
lifestyle except sometimes you can get
extreme it is it is a spectrum and the
thing that I really like about
minimalism its malleable for people who
have multiple kids but it's also
valuable for people who want to take it
a bit farther and let go of even more
and sort of test their limits and I
think you do a great job of
communicating that on your YouTube
channel you sort of bring an extreme
approach and and I'm using that word
because you use that word what what
propelled you or what convinced you that
extreme minimalism was a meaningful way
to live well first of all thanks for
having me here it's so nice to be in
your presence and so I started
minimalism five years ago back in New
York and I just didn't use that label
extreme actually until I started my
and I just felt that because I was so
deep into my own like cultivating my own
practice and continuing my journey and
being a mamillus from New York to making
my a move to Austin and having that
practice be there for me for five years
I just didn't know that what my
lifestyle was can be perceived as
extreme and then I had people telling me
that we are when you show yourself and
really share your life with other people
these these kind of choices that you
make may be very extreme for a lot of
people especially in American standards
so I started to think about how I can
demonstrate a different kind of
minimalism and in terms of limitation
that is going the limitation that's more
on a conscious everyday level and I want
to kind of use that word to convey that
part of myself yeah yeah no I think
that's great like would you do you feel
like you are in deprivation feel like
you're depriving yourself every day
because what when I see your YouTube
channel and when I see your lifestyle it
does seem a bit extreme compared to you
know how many things being my wife own
or the you know the way that we
accumulate things you know if it came to
things you would you put Josh and I to
shame you know like you're the real
minimalist if that's what it was about
wins the competition she totally wants a
competition but but but I don't see you
depriving yourself I see you living in
an intentional way where I feel like
you're not living in deprivation would
you agree with that I think the
conscious limitation that I share is
only a selective part of myself just
because I want to get the message true
that this is possible and that I can
thrive and be happy in this kind of
limited environment where I'm very
highly intentional with my limitations
so no yes you you might I want to dive
into a few things with you I want to
talk about some of the things you don't
buy I want to talk
about your furniture free minimalist
apartment I want to talk to you about
your laundry routine and sound
minimalism and a bunch of other things
but we usually start this show off as a
listener driven show I was hoping maybe
we could hop into a few of our callers
and answer some of their questions how
about we start yeah how about we start
with Jamie in Zanesville Ohio when you
have achieved the goal of becoming a
minimalist what is the next goal or
steps to progress towards I've already
minimized my stuff bad relationships etc
plus I live in a tiny house and I've
also rent a space out to guests on
Airbnb so I have been able to decrease
my working hours too
I just want to keep refining and
curating so where should I be going at
this point with my journey and many more
of them now um it seems to me that we
often mistake the the destination with
the the path there and for me minimalism
tends to be the path and Jamie has set
minimalism up as the destination has the
sort of goal and and I think when we do
that if we make the goal to buy a hammer
that's a weird goal right we need the
hammer as a tool to maybe fix something
and for me minimalism was a tool that
allowed me to to simplify my life and
what I've noticed with you and your
YouTube channel I've noticed that you
have used minimalism to to radically
simplify your life and and there does
become a point though where it's no
longer just about simplifying it's about
getting the stuff out of the way to make
room for something else right I feel
that for me minimalism is not really the
ultimate place that I want to arrive at
but it's the process and I think
minimalism for me is actually the result
of letting go within so I know that a
lot of people approach minimalism with
physically decluttering and physically
letting go of the material things but
for me the material things I'm able to
let go because I've worked on the inner
self and letting go of the attachment as
well as the obsession that I have to
material identity or anything that I am
obsessed in craving so the physical
conditions of a simple home of a minimal
aesthetic is just the manifestation of
what I've been doing inside ya know I
love these say that because you or
you're kind of at where Jamie is talking
about like yes you you don't have any
furniture you you wash your clothes by
hand you have these practices that you
could look at just the items and say oh
like okay I'm officially a minimalist
but you'reyou're able to use that as a
way to live your life and I think when I
hear Jamie asking what I really hear him
asking is what does he do with his time
now because what he has done is he has
it sounds like he's cut back on his
bills he's got a tiny house he's living
you know this this ostensible minimal
lifestyle so the question I hear I'm
asking is now what do I do with my
reclaimed time and and what I love about
your channel is like you've got for
example you've got hey this is what it
looks like when I work this is a day of
work for me and and I would really
highly recommend that Jamie check out
your channel um because that is because
that is certainly it's a good example of
what to do actually it's not even a
guide of what to do I think what your
YouTube channel shows is a recipe you're
like hey I have totally minimized my
stuff now here's what I do with my time
and and Jamie needs to decide for
himself how his time can be best spent
but certainly you know Josh and I what
we do with our time Josh and I do are
different what you do is different and I
think the hardest part about when you
have reclaimed your time it is figuring
out like oh no now I've got to be by
myself what do I do now right and Ryan
what I would say there is get really
clear on what your values are because
each of us might value different things
even though we we approach life with the
sort of minimal lens or the minimalists
lens and we're simplifying things but
then once we're making room for
something important we need to figure
out what we value and so Jamie I'm gonna
recommend we actually have a free values
worksheet on our website there's an
essay there called how to understand
your values and you can download that
use worksheet and really get clear on
the different types of values you know
we have these sort of foundational
values then we have the structural
values we have the surface values and we
have the imaginary values which are
quite often the things that we thought
were important in life but minimalism
helps us let go of those things that are
imaginary the the things that are in the
way so we can focus on what we actually
value and I'll tell you at Jamie you can
never go wrong with contributing it's
like my whole goal with what Josh and I
do is I want people to feel like they
have enough a because there's a sense of
security when you realize like oh I do
have enough and you can kind of deal
with those impulses and deal with that
constant wanting because that's the
society we live in it is like this
constant state of wanting I mean look at
the panic buying that's happening right
now it's like people feel like they have
to accumulate in order to stay safe and
what Josh and I and you you on what
we're trying to explain to people is
like yes you do need some things but it
might not be as much as you need and
when people feel like they have enough
that is when they start to look
externally I think you can totally give
even though you know maybe you're in
this state of wanting or maybe you're
you know you're someone who's very poor
like I think it's it's still it's still
totally possible to give however I think
when we feel like we have enough it's it
makes us feel like it's easier to give
so Jamie you can never go wrong with
contributing your time to helping out
your community into helping out Society
well a next question is from Tracy in
West Lafayette Indiana I have heard you
talk about your kids about your kitchen
excuse me and how you would be even more
of a minimalist in the kitchen if you
lived alone
I was curious what you eat and if you
could give some insight on your
minimalist way of life in the kitchen
alright so yes I have said this in the
past that I mean right now if you're
actually looking at the video version of
this you can see my living room it is
relatively sparse but if you go into my
kitchen my wife is a dietician and the
nutritionist and she requires more
instruments than I might require more
tools than I might require if I were
living oh he likes to cook she's got all
the cooking devices yeah you know
Ryan is funny he said I think that I've
rarely had a need for a kitchen at all
in the past when I was looking on my own
dude when you and I were living together
all we needed was the the rice cooker
yeah we were in the cabin in the middle
of nowhere yeah dude I mean that we
literally could have went without a
stove and just used the rice cooker and
we would have been okay I don't know
that we ever even turned the stove on
yeah and so the question is what are the
appropriate tools because quite often
and you oh my I'm sure you you can
recognize this - with your
experimentation but quite often we we
think that we need the things that other
people think they need or other people
think we need and so if I see a blender
in someone else's house I'm gonna get
that or if I see a juicer I'm gonna get
that or if I'm going to see this
particular skillet or a wok or a spatula
or whatever and there's nothing
inherently wrong with any of those
things the question is are they
appropriate for me and I'm not am I
going to use those things or did someone
else tell me that I need them yeah so
what's your kitchen look like um is
pretty maximal bystander's because
that's where all the action goes on in
my house is I eat a plant-based raw 8020
raw vegan lifestyle so there's a lot of
blenders and food processors which is
not that minimal but again to me it's
not really about curating the perfect
minimalist lifestyle and the matching my
kitchen to fit into that minimal
standard but it's more so that I just
listen to how I'm going to nourish my
body in the best way that I can within
my budget within my lifestyle and
condition and then manifesting were
matching the physical condition to be to
support the diet that I'm choosing I
think it's a great example you know
because even for someone like you who
has no you know no furniture in your
living room like to still show a piece
of your life where you're like hey I
probably have more utensil or not
utensils but more devices to cook with
than maybe the average person but it's
very intentional and you know it's
interesting I will you know Josh and I
we will swap out minimalism for
intentional ism or enough ISM because
some
you know when you hear that word
minimalism you think oh I've got to like
be a monk with bare white walls and just
eat rice for the rest of my life and the
the fact that there is still a balance
there I think that's I think that's an
awesome example they asked the question
also to josh was what's our diet and to
ask Josh what his diet is right now I
don't think anyone although maybe Paul
Saladino would agree with what your diet
is but right now I mean Josh yeah talk
about what your diet looks like right
now yeah well my diet has to do with I
have a lot of dietary restrictions just
based on you know the the ulcers that I
have in my small intestine and so it
radically limits what I'm able to eat
and unfortunately I'm not able to eat
many plants or much fiber right now and
so I have I have an extremely limited
diet but that one is out of necessity
right and and so sometimes it's about
intention and with respect to the things
we remove from our life because we think
it'll serve us better but sometimes we
have to we have to remove things out of
necessity and I think that's the an
important distinction to make because
you won't you might have quite a few
things in your kitchen
probably not relative to the average
American household but relative to your
living room now but if I were to swap
out your your blender for a couch that
would actually but that that would not
serve a purpose in fact it would get in
the way of what you're trying to
accomplish with with your own lifestyle
and so us trying to live like someone
else because someone else has a couch or
someone else has a blender the question
then is what is appropriate for my life
so that I can live a practical life with
less stuff and quite often I think that
involves simplifying now Tracy I'd love
to send you a copy of our book
everything that remains it's the story
of me and Ryan we were out in that cabin
in the middle of nowhere when we wrote
this book actually and and it's a story
of us being these suit-and-tie corporate
guys having way way way too much stuff
but then sort of radically simplify our
lives to find and live a more practical
life and even Ryan's in my version of
minimalism might be extreme for some
people
but what we try to show in that book is
it's actually a much more practical
lifestyle than you might suspect by
getting rid of the excess we're able to
really figure out and then focus on
what's truly important so Tracy if you
like our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version of everything that
remains or if you want the book book or
the eBook version I'll be happy to send
those to you as well Ryan Josh I think
he just came up with a really good
reality show idea I think it's gonna be
called would you rather have a couch oh
you know what time it is it is time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages you could text your
questions and comments to nine three
seven two zero two four six five four
yes indeed those text messages actually
go straight to both of our phones and so
during this whole pandemic right now
which we've already covered extensively
on this podcast you can text us we've
got a little bit more time also once
this whole pandemics over we will be
setting up some new free meetups in
different cities throughout the United
States and Canada and if you want
details about those the only way you're
going to find out is if you are on our
text message group now we can't answer
every question but we do our best to
reply to as many people as we can and we
even answer some questions on the
podcast or in this lightning round now
the lightning round um what we try to do
is we answer answer questions with just
a short shareable less than 140
character response and we put the text
to these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so people can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if they'd
like and by the way folks can find all
of our minimal Maxim's in one place now
over at minimal Maxim's dot-com but um
don't worry we just ramble on a little
bit people ask questions and then Shawn
makes it beautiful in the the show notes
Ryan what's our question fellas Cody
wants to know Josh and um what is the
absolute minimum number of physical
items you think you would need to
survive
413 I was gonna say 412 thank you men
what I don't need underwear here's my
pithy answer and you and I love to hear
what you have to say about this with my
short answer is
don't confuse surviving with thriving
and Ryan earlier talked about
deprivation we don't want to deprive
ourselves of the things that we need but
sometimes we can temporarily deprive
ourselves we can remove something from
our life for a period of time and
determine whether or not it was actually
adding value and then we can bring it
back in in a more deliberate sort of way
but if we we can get rid of anything and
so Cody's question about the minimum
number of physical items you need to
survive I don't want to just survive I
mean maybe that that number is close to
zero right we look at our ancestors you
look at pre civilization we didn't even
own things maybe we had a spear or maybe
we had you know a few tools but only
what we could carry on our person and
and so I think the number is probably
close to zero but that's not thriving
necessarily and so maybe the better
question is how many items do you need
personally to to thrive you and what do
you think about that depends on what
your method of survival is so if your
method of survival is having good people
around feeding off of their energy and
then emanating good energy and vibration
then that to me is my own way of
survival so then I need zero yeah no I
love that no it's such a good point I
mean what people need to survive it's
gonna be it's gonna be different for
each person
my pet the answer is this monks live
with nothing minimalists live with
what's appropriate and that's really
what we're talking about here is what's
appropriate for your life Cody I mean if
you want to challenge yourself and do
like some kind of man in the wild
situation where you're living with
absolutely nothing and seeing if you can
survive you know good on you Josh and I
that's not what how we want to survive
and that's not an experiment that I want
to do myself but yeah if we're focusing
on the number of things I think we're
focusing on the wrong things yeah um it
doesn't seem to me that you you are
necessarily counting your items and it
you you have in your life what is
appropriate for you right now but it you
also seem you know based off the videos
I've watched of yours on on your YouTube
channel
it seems to me that you're willing to
adjust that if you think something is
going to add value to your life you're
willing to bring it back in and also if
something stops adding value to your
life you're obviously willing to let it
go as well you know Josh I was talking
and um I was talking to my grandmother
this morning because I had to ship her
facial tissue because there's no toilet
paper for her she lives at this
retirement community and they were able
to give her a couple rolls but you know
just enough to get by until I shipped
her some facial tissue because I
couldn't find toilet paper anywhere and
she was explaining to me she grew up in
Germany in lawsuit Germany it's just
society Munich during World War two and
she was explaining to me how little that
she had to live with during those war
times and she was kind of going on and
on about the people that's in her
community that are just they have no
idea what it's like to live with nothing
but you know my she was telling me
things about how literally she would get
like a slice of bread and an apple for
lunch and she was so hungry as a kid she
would eat it on the way to school so she
wouldn't have a lunch and the teacher
would end up like when all the kids were
gone she would pull my grandmother aside
and shoo but like here here have my
Apple because you know the kids but
that's what they used to do with
teachers is bring them apples or a pear
whatever she had one time all they had
were egg noodles and jelly and that's
what her mom made for dinner and it was
just I mean it so you know it you don't
need a lot to survive but you know
living in a situation like that I
totally agree with you Josh it's it's
not thriving all right before we get
into our added value segment and our
listener tips today it looks like we've
got a bunch more surprise questions to
talk about this week Ryan let's see here
what are the pros and cons if any of
extreme minimalism do you know any
extreme minimalist with kids I'm gonna
say yes to that but I'm also gonna leave
you some examples also are you truly
happy here the real question well we're
gonna talk to you um about the things
she doesn't buy anymore as Extreme
minimalist what are some of the things
that she refuses to buy and why she
doesn't buy them we're gonna talk about
her Furniture free apartment which I am
just astounded by I love her video about
this but I want her to
also we'll talk about her minimalist
laundry routine her sound minimalism
we're gonna talk about sleeping in a
hammock she doesn't have a bed but she
sleeps in a hammock we're gonna talk
about living with someone else even
though you are an extreme minimalist and
they are not and we're also gonna talk
about extreme minimalist cleaning at
home plus we've got a bunch more
questions for you um and if you wanna
hear all that listen to this week's
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast that's right you're
currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
and our guests record an entirely
different much longer maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast it's just
two bucks and it is the most honest way
for this podcast to earn an income
because we don't believe in
advertisements you know we think
advertisements suck so we make money
only if you find value in and support
what we create this is especially
important right now in these trying
times where Ryan and I are relying on
the the podcast to get this message of
minimalism out to more people than ever
because we're not able to do some of the
speaking gigs or the touring that we
would typically do so the podcast is a
great way for us to share this message
and you can support that and the
minimalists com slash support by the way
when you subscribe to the minimalist
private podcast you'll also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app this is an entirely separate
endeavor and you can find it at the
minimalists com slash support riah what
else you got for us this week here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out I was
listening to a TED talk by David
Christian who talks about big history in
his talk he started with the Big Bang
and the beginning of the universe but at
one point he said gravity is more
powerful when there's more stuff I think
this applies not only to the universe
but to our lives cluttered rooms tables
and desks invite more clutter to
gravitate to it for those who feel
overwhelmed I make the suggestion pick a
space your desk your dining room table
your bedroom and have a minor packing
party take everything out of the area
it thoroughly than only allowed back in
or on what belongs there as you need it
once you've cleared the area make it a
priority to keep it cleared for me this
started in my bedroom which became a
tidy restful sanctuary now nothing comes
in that doesn't belong and everything is
put in its place immediately
then it's spread to the dining room
table a notorious horizontal surface
that used to invite clutter slowly my
entire house became more tidy without me
ever saying anything to my family no one
wanted to be the person who threw stuff
down on the dining room table as it was
clean and had fresh flowers on him we
all now take pride in our tidy home
without me once ever preaching
minimalism as the clutter disappeared
the spaces became easier to maintain and
the entire family feels less stressed
we did a couple of birthdays and
Christmases and tried to ask people not
to bring gifts but of course family
members always want to give you stuff
and honestly I usually let the kids play
with it for a week or so and it all ends
up at the thrift store anyways so this
last year we decided to start adopting
animals and we have an animal Ark that
is just outside of Reno that rescues and
rehabilitates wild animals and animals
that have been raised in captivity and
whatnot but you can donate to them you
can pick which animal you want to adopt
and you can donate to them throughout
the year so we adopted a wolf and at any
of our kids birthdays we now put on the
invitation that if they would like to
bring a present if they'd like to donate
money to the wolf they can we also
adopted an elephant I think we actually
just fed the elephant for a day from the
elephant sanctuary which is located in
Tennessee we adopted an elephant for my
mom for Christmas a couple years ago so
now since she loves elephants she gets a
monthly email newsletter about how her
elephant is doing and she really loves
that so that could be a great way to get
people involved they feel happy giving
you something and then they can continue
to follow that animal online alright so
thanks again to um for joining us today
please check out her YouTube channel
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes I think you're really going to
enjoy her videos she has a lot of them
and you can really appreciate the
aesthetic side of extreme mental ism but
then go way beyond the aesthetics to the
sort of inner peace that she helps
people create and real quick for right
here right now here is one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
we're back to vlogging over on YouTube
you can check out our new vlog it's
called a meaningful life episode number
three Ryan you and I and and podcast
Shawn and Jordan no more we just went
out to Utah last month and we captured a
bunch a bunch of footage of us roaming
around Utah land
winter we went to a jazz game but also
most important we finished the
soundtrack to our next film les is now
and we were down there with Nate Peiffer
and the folks from we which is the band
that they created just for our first
film and now there they've come back
together to do the soundtrack for our
second film and you can check out our
vlog from our entire journey over to
Utah we also did an unscripted Utah
Meetup where we just send a text message
out to our text message group by the way
you can join us for any of our future
unscripted events just send us a text
message to get added to our list nine
three seven two oh two four six five
four if you do that you also get our
Monday morning minimal Maxim's every
Monday we start your week off with just
a pithy phrase to help inspire you for
the week over on our YouTube channel
though check out episode three of a
meaningful life it is our newest vlog of
us exploring Utah and trying to live a
meaningful life while we travel you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast just
email voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
e-mail list over at the minimalists comm
right there at the top you also receive
our simple Sunday emails each week some
new writings about minimalism never junk
never spam never advertisements because
we don't believe in any of those things
now Ryan for our added value this week
have you heard Jay electronic his new
album
I have not all at the second I've never
even heard of Jay Electronica
well here's the thing back in like 2009
he he was sort of touted as the next big
thing the next jay-z or nas and then for
11 years he never put out an album he
had a couple like just Lucy's songs that
were out but nothing that was a full
body of work he had this amazing song
back in 2009 called Exhibit C which was
just this I mean this exceptional
expression of penmanship and lyricism
what an amazing song it was and now he's
finally released his debut album it's
it's called a written test
but here's something unique about this
jay-z is on almost every song on this
album and there's only nine songs on the
album and so people are comparing it to
the Watch the Throne album from 2011
even though it's it's not that at all
it's a completely different endeavor but
it's Jay Electronica but also featuring
jay-z throughout most of the album and
the the song I want to finish with today
is a song called neverending story if
you leave here today with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listen y'all
we'll see you next time and minimus